So the latest mathematical fact
taking the internet by
storm, well, you may
have seen it.
Let's check this out.
I don't know if you
have seen it.
It's been all over
the internet.
I'm going to take 1 divided
by 998,001.
If you take that fraction, what
you get, if you do the
decimal for it, you get
something rather remarkable.
You get every single
three-digit number.
It starts with 0 point,
and it goes 0, 0, 0.
So that's 0.
And it goes 0, 0, 1.
There's 1.
0, 0, 2--
0, 0, 3--
0, 0, 4--
0, 0, 5.
And it will give you every
single there-digit number
except for one.
It doesn't give you 998.
Every single three-digit
number except 998.
OK, so let's go on.
So it goes 6, 7, skip a few.
Then it'll go 9, 9, 6--
9, 9, 7.
There is no 998.
It goes 9, 9, 9, and then
it starts again.
It'll go back to 0, 0, 0, and
then 0, 0, 1, and goes to
start again.
It repeats.
So, we had a lot of people email
us about this, and one
of our favorite YouTubers,
Vsauce, gives us a little
shoutout and asked us
about it as well.
And so, we had to make
a video about this.
We have seen this before.
It's not as remarkable
as you may think.
So this is a repeating
decimal.
For start, I want to show you
that this is part of a family
of similar facts.
So, one thing to notice
is 998001.
This is actually 999 squared.
Now, this is why we've got a
little family of facts here,
because if I took 1 over 9,801,
this is actually 1 over
99 squared.
Same sort of idea.
And what you would get are all
the numbers, all the two-digit
numbers for that.
So you would get 0.0001020304.
So it's the same idea.
You get all the two-digit
numbers except
for 98 in that case.
Very similar idea.
9998001.
It's the same sort of idea.
Again, this is 1 over
9999 squared.
And you get all the four-digit
numbers.
What about 1 over 9 squared?
Now, that's the one I really
want to show you, because we
wanted to make this
a bit simple, OK?
Let's not go straight into it.
Let's take the simplest
example.
1 over 9 squared.
So, 1/81.
That's what we're going to look
at, 1 over 9 squared.
And that will give you all
the one-digit numbers.
0.01234567.
It missed 8.
9, and then back to 0 again.
It repeats that pattern.
So, it's the same idea.
So, let's see if we can work out
why this is true, and then
this idea will work for the
other examples that
we've seen so far.
Right.
Do you want another
piece of paper?
I do need another
piece of paper.
Let's get you more paper.
So, the easiest explanation for
this is that we could make
any repeating decimal that
we wanted to make.
So, if you wanted to
make, say, this.
Let's say it's going to start
with naught point, and let's
take some digits.
Let's call it a1, that's
the first digit.
a2, the second digit.
a3.
And let's say it's, I don't
know, n digits long.
And then it repeats, so you
get the same thing.
It goes dot, dot, dot, and you
get that repeated over and
over again.
You can make that
quite easily.
All you have to do to make that
is to take this little
sequence, a1, a2, a3, up to an,
and divide it by the same
number of 9s.
You've got n nines here.
9, 9, 9, whatever
number that is.
So those two things
would be equal.
For our example, then, for 1/81,
we wanted 0.012345679,
dot, dot, dot.
012345679 over 999999999.
And that would give you that
decimal representation, and
that does simplify.
That makes a nice 1/81.
Now, you could make any
repeating decimal using that
method, but there is something
special about that, because it
simplifies so nicely.
It makes such a nice number.
So, not all fractions like this
would make a nice number,
so why is it so nice?
Let me try and show you that.
So here's a little formula.
If you study mathematics, here's
a little formula that
you will learn, perhaps
at some point, anyway.
Let me show you what it is.
A little expression.
It starts with 1 plus
2x plus 3x squared
plus 4x cubed plus--
and that can go on
forever, OK?
So imagine this little
equation.
Now, here's a little
cool thing.
If your number x is
less than 1--
in fact, this works for negative
numbers as well if
they're greater than minus 1.
What I'm saying is
if the size--
and that symbol means the size
of x-- if it's less than 1,
this actually really
simplifies to
something pretty cool.
It becomes 1 over 1
minus x squared.
And isn't that cool?
That complicated thing that goes
on forever, actually if
your x is less than 1, it's the
same as that, will give
you the same answer.
That's pretty cool.
That's pretty cool, isn't it?
Right.
So, we're going to use this
to work out our fraction.
OK, so if I let x equal
1/10, what do I get?
On this side--
I think I'll write
it as a column--
I get 1, 2x.
So two times 1/10, that's 0.2,
and you add them together.
This one is 3x squared,
which is 0.03.
Plus 4x cubed equals 0.004.
And you keep going,
dot, dot, dot.
Keep going forever.
All this on the left
is equal to--
on this side, if x is 1/10,
well, let's see.
1 minus 1/10 is 9/10 squared.
9/10 squared is 81/100.
And because it's 1 over that
fraction, you flip it.
This is equal to 100/81.
So all this is 1.23456
equals 100/81.
The one we're interested in
was actually just the same
thing, but just 100
times smaller.
You just had to shift it across
a couple of places.
So that's why you've got
such a neat, cool
fraction out of that.
Really simple.
But why is it missing the 8?
Now, that's interesting.
Why is it missing the 8?
Check this out.
Let's go a few down.
Let's do the 8.
Naught point-- let me see,
I'm going to need six
of those, then 8.
Let's do the next one.
Naught point seven more.
Then there's the 9.
And if I want to add 10,
it's going to 0--
try again--
point.
Now 0000000--
now, I want to write 010 here,
but there is no symbol for 10.
I can't write 010.
I have to write 10, like that.
Now, if you add this all
together, you just add up the
columns, just a column
at a time, can you
see it carries on?
Like you learned at school,
this carries on.
So this 1 plus 9, the 9 turns
into a 10, so that carries on.
So you get 1 plus 8, and
that becomes a 9.
Your 8 becomes a 9.
Your missing 8 turns into
a 9 because of all
this carrying on.
So all this is like a
row of dominoes .
You get a carry on, carry
on, carry on.
Your 8 turns into a 9, it
disappears, and you get that
number we discovered.
And the same sort of idea will
work for all those other
fractions that we looked at.
So the 1/998,001 is
the same idea.
You can prove the same thing
with the same idea.
It's a cool fact, isn't it?
It's a cool, little fact.
Yeah, I like the fact.
And it's not completely trivial,
but you can make any
repeating decimal that you want
to make, so that's not
particularly remarkable.
Why has it suddenly gone
on the internet?
Who knows?
You get these things
ever now and again.
These things go viral.
Mathematicians can roll their
eyes and go, oh, no, not this.
Oh, you're boring.
But every now and again, for no
reason as far as I can see,
you get this happening.